good afternoon members and officers uh
welcome to this extraordinary meeting of
the cabinet
um
members you are you all have your papers
with you um
as you all know the the meeting is being
cast
live so that members of the public can
see
our deliberations and we also have
a number of our
officers
on screen
so without further ado um
first item um
liz apologies for absence
we have apologies from councillor
jefferson
and you also have an apology for me for
forgetting who you actually were
[Laughter]
ann any disclosures of interest
any of any cabinet member have a
disclosure of interest
okay so we move now to matters for
decision by the cabinet
under the leader oblique resources
portfolio item three
revenue and capital budgets 2022 oblique
23 to 2026 week 27 which are pages 1
through 82 of your agenda papers um i'm
going to start with
asking the portfolio holder councillor
harvey uh to say anything that he may
wish to say at this point and then i
will move on to
um
mr snow
to similarly uh outline any points that
he feels are pertinent and relevant to
our discussion and debates
and then i'll open up to
to members of the cabinet in the first
instance i also know councillor junior
in attendance counselor
are you in attendance in relation
thank you deputy leader
normally when i have a finance paper to
introduce i i i'm very deliberate about
what i say and hence i write it out
beforehand
so that i know what uh
what i'm to be held accountable for
in this particular instance i haven't
done that and i haven't done that for a
particular reason and that is that we
are at a formal stage here
this is
82 pages of
detailed proposals which form the basis
will form the basis
uh subject to approval for our
consultation with interested parties and
therefore the issues and the arguments
that are contained within the budget
proposal
are not for discussion today
i think
um
i i don't intend to debate them i think
that that uh debate takes place once
we've had the consultation with
interested parties and we know
what are the bones that are being picked
so to speak the alterations and
amendments that are being suggested it's
at that stage that we have the
substantive debate
what i would like to do is to simply
thank the officers concerned because
they have worked
under
severe time pressures in order to
produce
this particular set of proposals
the
although we knew that the uh the terms
of the settlement uh were
due
by the end of or by the middle of
december they did arrive late uh people
have worked over the over the christmas
period to produce these these these
papers
it's a team effort
there's a lot of work involved
and i do whatever we think about the
quality of the proposals put forward the
amount of work that goes into actually
producing these 82 pages within the time
scale does need to be acknowledged and i
take my hat off to
mike to richard and and to their staff
on that basis i'm quite happy to propose
the recommendation set out on on page
one i will not read them all out they'll
they are lengthy and they are before you
um
and on their basis i
return matters to you seek um
mr snow's point of view and seek a
second for that proposal thank you
thank you councillor harvey i do see
councillor kettle indicating
very happy second council uh council
harvest proposal
thank you very much councillor kettle um
i see councillor junior due indicating a
wish to speak would you wish to do so
now or would you wish to hear from mr
snow first of all at all i i just wanted
to raise a couple of things mr snow
might be able to clarify because they're
just quick queries if i'm not so would
you like to raise those now to afford mr
snow the opportunity to
respond to those in in encompassing his
other remarks yeah of course then
councillor junior after you okay um one
of them is about the capital program
10.1 i just want to seek some
clarification uh because the revenue
cost of the
joint waste contract vehicles are being
included
um and it says um
that if w
monik district house does not does
acquire the vehicles this capital budget
and accompanying borrowing will not be
required by sdc so showing an underspend
on the council's program the basic um
detail on query is
could there be any indication at all of
when that will will know
for sure exactly what that position is
uh and my second
question is um i just want clarification
about the whether or not they the
government promised 75 support for
losses on certain fees including car
parking and planning have been included
in the support for this year or is that
still to be clarified
do i see the chief executive indicating
to make a comment there at all i didn't
want to be two pedantry councillor but
which year when you've referred to this
year are you looking at
2022-23 or the first i think i
understand it was just the first quarter
of 21 22
that the the compensation scheme was in
place for losing revenue uh that that's
what i said the kind of clarification i
was wishing to have okay thank you mike
okay so so with that um mr snow uh but
before may i just add my thanks and
those of the rest of the cabinet and
indeed other senior members of this
authority who will be and other members
of the authority in addition who will be
pouring over the detail of this in
future to come to its deliberations
around the budget to thank you and your
team uh particularly richard uh as well
for uh for the work that you've done to
uh bring all this to this point so uh
the floor is yours mr snow
right okay thank you thank you
especially for all the comments um
which i mean to be honest i think it's
richard and the team that must take far
greater credit for bringing it all
together and i
with all the detailed work that's been
going on for several months in getting
to this situation
but by way of summary um about the
budget i mean it is a what we're
presenting here today
it is a
presenting a balanced budget it's a
balanced budget you know balancing the
budget for the fourth coming year and
also for future years looking at the
medium-term financial strategy
um within the budget we have got various
savings which is the same savings i
think which we've got as detailed in the
report which we need to obviously as uh
as members and as officers we need to
meet make sure we all work and are
committed to delivering on all of those
savings or otherwise that would present
a risk to the the budget
we have got various items of growth as
well included in the budget which uh
again as detailed there
and along with the proposals for the
fees and charges capital programme
and the council tax proposal which we
know will go on for to be debated
further
in terms of the medium-term financial
strategy there's obviously a lot of
assumptions have to go into this the
further we go
into the future especially on the any
external funding be it in terms of
our share of retained business rates or
any other government grant funding that
we we may well get obviously things like
revenue support grant is a thing of the
past now for us
so there are definitely risks attached
to the the funding there but we believe
you know whilst we don't want to be
overly prudent but we do believe you
know we have it is right to be
somewhat prudent in those projections
going forward
and then just uh in terms of the within
the medium-term financial strategy the
having made all the savings we've got
factored into there by the end of the
fifth year we do present
almost a balanced budget for that final
year 59 000 pound shortfall which
bearing in mind we're sort of talking
five years away and we're talking about
turnover of sort of 17 million pounds
at this stage you know i think anybody
will be pleased if they can actually get
to the situation of just presenting a 59
000 pound shortfall and alongside that
we throughout we are maintaining whilst
we're using the general fund reserve to
get to that position and helping to
support the the budgets in the future
years but by the end of that fifth year
we are in a situation of having 2.5
million still in the general fund
reserve
um in terms of a couple of questions
from councillor june ed
the capital program yes we've got the
vehicle waste which was
the vehicles uh for the waste contract
which we agreed that we would fund those
rather than the contractor funding those
so hence they were factored into the
um the capital program and warwick
working out as with all of this contract
it's best to work jointly so warwick are
looking to
um have all of the funding on their
balance sheet and actually to buy the
vehicles
and that is what we are working to at
the moment but of course we've still got
to have um full confirmation that all of
those orders
uh will be uh well the orders have been
placed but we still need confirmation
confirmation of the delivery of those
vehicles and which of course we should
be getting i believe quite shortly but
of course you know within the next
couple of months we should know if
there's going to be any problems and if
we have to resort to
any other courses of actions acquiring
the vehicles which is why we've left in
that capital budget at this stage but we
don't anticipate we should need it
either way in terms of the
the revenue account whilst if we were
acquiring the vehicles ourselves we
would have our own debt charges interest
and
repayments of capital on on our going
through our revenue account
the uh was its warwick that will be
acquiring the vehicles they will just be
recharging us our proportion which again
so you know on the revenue account it
should work out the same either way
in terms of the fees and charges the 75
percent which is uh the chief executive
referred to for the first quarter of
this year is it is just the first
quarter this year um just look at uh
mr burrell there which i believe that
ful that full income has been built into
the factory in the recovery
years
could you just come to the table and
step to a mic so that we can all hear
you thank you very much
hello you hear it you can now thank you
yeah we didn't budget for it like i say
the um
we didn't know the schemes
would exist until we entered this
financial year so in 2122 we didn't
budget to receive that money
um
but it will be within
the revenue out term position which will
contribute to reserves
sure maybe
yes of course that's a really important
point so whilst it wasn't initially
positive for the amount of the reserve
general fund opening balance for 22 23
does assume that we have received
whatever income that we have in in
determining the outcome position for the
current year so
there is there isn't a resource to add
back in it has been included
thank you very much
nothing further from
members you have
the budget papers before you you have
nine recommendations before you on page
one i'm
not seeing anybody wishing to
have any further debate ask any further
questions
so on that basis if we have a proposal
and a second i do intend that we take
all nine recommendations
on block
um and the recommendations are as
outlined on page one i shan't take the
time to to read those out
so all of those in favor please indicate
anonymous
thank you very much indeed uh members of
cabinet
uh the budget process will now continue
its way through its further round of
stakeholding um before uh
coming to
the final recommendations which will be
considered at the cabinet to be held on
february the 7th
now move to item 4 any urgent business
i'm not aware of any urgent business
members i'm not aware of any urgent
business and i therefore call the
meeting to a close and thank you for
your attendance
you